MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Xiaowen.
XIAOWEN XIN: Hi, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: You're a
product manager focusing
on serverless security, right?
XIAOWEN XIN: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great,
because I have some developer
questions for you about
software supply chain security.
XIAOWEN XIN: Great to hear, and
it's one of my favorite topics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
So Xiaowen, I hear
from developers who
are worried that they
might be vulnerable to
software supply chain attacks.
In the recent SolarWinds
attack, the attacker
compromised the build platform,
and in the Codecov attack,
the attacker uploaded
an artifact that was not
built by the CI/CD system.
How can I protect my system?
XIAOWEN XIN: Well, Martin,
it's a complex problem,
and we want to help
developers navigate it.
One thing you can do today is
to use Binary Authorization
to make sure that only
approved builds can
get deployed to Google
Kubernetes Engine or Cloud
Run in your project.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great, because
I have a Cloud Run service
here that I'd like to
secure so that no one can
bypass my CI/CD pipeline.
Can you walk me through it?
XIAOWEN XIN: Sure.
And I know that you use Cloud
Build for your CI/CD pipeline,
so let's first enable Binary
Authorization on your project.
You go into the Cloud Console
and click the hamburger menu.
Then select Security and
Binary Authorization.
Click Enable to turn on the API.
Now let's deploy your
Cloud Run service again.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, OK.
Doing so now.
This will also take a minute.
XIAOWEN XIN: And now
that it's been deployed,
let's go back to Binary
Authorization and click
Attestors.
You will see that an attestor
has been automatically created.
From now on, this attestor will
cryptographically sign every
build done in Cloud Build so
we know where it comes from.
The signed attestation includes
provenance information,
such as the source code
that it was built from
and the commands
used to build it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
And what will we do
with this attestor?
XIAOWEN XIN: Good question.
If we go back to
the Policy tab, we
see that there is a
default policy here
that allows all
images to be deployed.
Let's update this
policy to require
that all builds must be
signed by that attestor
before they can be deployed.
And in other words, all builds
must come from your Cloud Build
pipeline.
Click Edit Policy, select
Require Attestations,
click Add Attestors, and
in the Attestor name box,
you can select
built-by-cloud-build
in the dropdown.
Then click to add this attestor.
Click Save Policy.
Now let's review the
policy again and confirm
that we're requiring images to
be approved by this attestor,
meaning that all images
must come from Cloud Build.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, OK.
Is this policy now being
enforced on my service?
XIAOWEN XIN: Not just yet.
Right now, any authenticated
user with the right IAM
permissions can still deploy
images and containers,
regardless of where
they were built.
MARTIN OMANDER: How
do I lock that down?
XIAOWEN XIN: Let's go back
to your Cloud Run service
and click the Details tab.
Where it says Binary
Authorization, click Enable.
Now the policy is
guarding this service
from containers built
outside your project.
MARTIN OMANDER: I
feel better now.
If I tried to deploy
a container that
wasn't built by Cloud
Build in this project,
will the system
refuse to deploy it?
XIAOWEN XIN: Yeah.
Try it out.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, I
will go here to Cloud Run.
I happen to know
that Google provides
a sample container for testing.
I don't know how that
container was built,
but I do know that
it wasn't built
by Cloud Build in my project.
Let's try to deploy it.
XIAOWEN XIN: And it looks
like the deployment failed.
MARTIN OMANDER: Perfect,
just what I want.
Containers built in my
project can be deployed,
but not containers
built by others.
Now what if I forget
to turn on Binary
Authorization for my service?
Is there a way to make sure that
Binary Authorization protects
all the services in my project?
XIAOWEN XIN: Yes,
glad you asked.
We support an
organization policy
for Binary Authorization.
Let's go turn that on.
Click the hamburger menu, then
IAM & Admin, then Organization
Policies.
Select Allowed
Binary Authorization
Policies for Cloud Run.
Then click Edit.
And let's customize this
policy and add a rule that
allows the default policy.
Click Done, then Save.
This will take effect
within a few minutes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that was also easy.
XIAOWEN XIN: Yeah.
And this protects
against attackers,
but it also helps you ensure
that your builds are consistent
and that no one in
your organization
accidentally deploys containers
built on their laptops
or on other places.
MARTIN OMANDER: I like that.
Now we've plugged one
hole here, and viewers
should be able to try this
at home pretty easily.
If they set this up
today, their projects
would be a little bit safer.
But Xiaowen, what is
the bigger picture here?
How can an organization get
up to speed on software supply
chain security overall?
XIAOWEN XIN: Great question.
Google and the
broader community have
launched a website
called Supply Chain
Levels for Software Artifacts.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that's a mouthful.
XIAOWEN XIN: It's
abbreviated to SLSA,
which is pronounced salsa, and
the website is at slsa.dev.
On that website, you can
learn about a framework
for assessing the security
of your supply chain
and gradually increasing
that security level.
We welcome everyone
to work with us
to level up the supply chain
security for the whole software
ecosystem.
And in fact, what we
did together today
with Cloud Build and Binary
Authorization already
meets quite a few of
those requirements.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
Thank you for
joining me, Xiaowen.
XIAOWEN XIN: You're welcome.
MARTIN OMANDER: And thank
you, everyone, for watching.
If you have
questions for Xiaowen
or me about Binary Authorization
or feedback on this episode,
post them in the comments.
Also, please let us know what
other serverless topics you'd
like to hear about on the show.
Bye for now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]